talent
without work ethic
it was a wasted opportunity i'm always
curious about that like who was the
greatest painter of all time
but she or he never decided to paint yo
estamos conchico right here in atlanta
and the reason we are here today doing
this interview okay with this carly head
is because of garyvee well one of the
main reasons we built this because
garyvee motivated me to do it yo garyvee
you gotta talk to me man i need your
help
i'm still grinding but we gotta do it
man all right crazy
and there they go you were born in
panama or your family's from panama yeah
i was born in panama you were yeah i was
born i was raised in panama until i was
10.
yeah and
yeah 2010 my mom ended up getting shot
because of my family gang activities i'm
sorry panama and
she
didn't hesitate brought me in my brother
she's like get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
my dad's american
he was never in the picture so it was
good
she took a shot she just
found herself immigrant came no papers
no job no no
yeah just came and that's what's up yeah
pretty much i've been living in atlanta
since 2011.
how'd the music gonna start
a friend invited me
to his house i just landed from visiting
panama for the first time that's when i
was in visit
yeah how old were you oh if i was like
17.
17
17. i'm 19 now
so just a couple years ago yeah
just a couple years ago and he invited
me and said yo there's some friends from
school everybody will put in my basement
if you want to come through
do you want to make a song
and you were like what oh yeah
but i ended up saying shirt for some
reason
i was like
some intuitive [ __ ] yeah like sure i
went
sure
i ended up recording a full song that
day and then 30 minutes later i made a
soundcloud
uploaded that song soundcloud but the
next day the song had like almost 2000
streams and i was like wow you were
addicted i was like okay
this is cool did it come natural natural
like i have and do you have do you have
any relatives that are about music or
anything like nothing on the radar i
think if i'm correct my grandma she
really likes singing but she never
pursued it she never talked about it so
i was like oh yeah i wasn't really a
soccer i was going to be a soccer player
sounds like a good panama kid yeah
and
yeah after that
i really liked the community i went home
i remember that day
and i was like yo i really like this
city it was fun i have fun
and
i go to school next day
i'm like yo well there's so many people
in the front door wait
and
as i get closer to the door
yo
your [ __ ] was fired it's just fire you
should keep making music you're like
what the [ __ ]
i didn't know you could do i was like i
didn't know myself
you didn't know i didn't [ __ ] know i
was
wow
and then that friend
his cousin
was is actually a producer and
he came through all the way from
snowville which is like an hour away
from here
as we are right now
he can't he will come like every once a
week or every two weeks so we can record
and we just kept doing that
over and over and just getting better
and better and throughout during the
pandemic
obviously we weren't allowed to go out
right so you have to really
strict as far so what he did
he snuck me into his house i took a 50
uber which i asked my mom for was 50
which she was gonna use to pay the light
bill
she gave them to me still
i took that uber
and that day i made a song called the
move
and that's the song i believe
yeah and that's the only song i recorded
during the pandemic and
i uploaded that song with my distro kit
yep i pitched the song to spotify and
you know i'm gonna play instead
it's crazy my friend pud
from back in my early internet days
um
was the founder of distrokid created it
and i remember him telling me like what
he was doing and i remember thinking
because i was me and boyd were already
tight yeah and i was like this is gonna
help all those people
and to just like sit here 15 years later
or whatever it is and hear you tell your
story
should just feel so emotional it's crazy
it is crazy i i tell people i'm like
does it just do you right now or no i
write all my songs even the first one
so the first one you were in there and
you were just like trying to yeah i just
kind of got like
a rhythm and then
it took me like a while obviously get
your cadence okay i've never done this
so of course
but you've listened to so much music
music that i was like and you always
[ __ ] with it like you always loved
listening music i was it was it felt
more of like a passion listening to
music for me like you know when you
listen to music and you enjoy for me it
was like a passion you need the movie to
come a friend to come in like i would
it's time for you
oh it's okay like i would um i would
literally like it would be a passion
listening to music i remember on the way
to school i couldn't keep my headphones
out
in class i couldn't get my headphones on
i made a deal with my teachers to have
one headphone and one now and because
she was like you seem like you can't
let it go and i was like i don't know
what it is like i just can't stop this
it's amazing
and she made a deal with me she said
fine one headphone in one out and good
for her
i love teachers that can
yeah teachers that can adjust
to a kid
have like i admire them so much not just
following the direct path and when you
think about your journey like
it's teachers like that that matter yeah
i went back to my school
um
i think late last year
and i saw some of the teachers and it
was like wow i'm so shook that's right
here i'm like why i was like i had to
come back and just say thank you
so much
and then i explained to them and
everything and i was like wow that's so
crazy like it's literally what are you
thinking about now
right now yeah at this moment not write
this exactly like within the macro like
how are you thinking about the lab what
do you think about the last couple weeks
and what are you thinking about like for
the rest of this year
wow that's a lot i mean
in the last couple weeks i've
done things i never thought i was going
to do
like i was never i never thought that
i'll have like
people organizing this stuff for me and
that's like yo you have this and you
have to go here to do this
video and this this and meet so many
people and get so much love from people
it's like almost like surprising
like people come home
and the store if people come out yo i
love your music like honestly thank you
so much people
text me like yo thank you so much
because of you i'm actually learning how
to speak spanish so i can communicate
with my friends
it's like outside of just making music
it's like actually making an impact yeah
100 percent my goal i was like that's
the best part about music it's a medium
that
[ __ ] just transcends everything yeah
it's so powerful it is like
which artist did you really
did any artists come like when your
teenage years really hit you
what was my love post i loved
it
it was real yeah it's real and all
points it's just real
it's one of those guys that i really
like look up doing that has actually
inspired me a lot it's nice and
i will also say
in the last like year or so saint john
man
yeah
that guy's fine
that guy's like the guy that i'm like
this guy is different he is different
super different and i'm like
stylish flow
yeah i i think like when you're capable
of being comfortable being your complete
self
you can win no matter what you could
look like the last 30 people in a row
look like a prototypical like when they
were doing all the you know everybody
looked like britney spears and jessica
simpson or everybody looks like boys to
man or everybody looks like you know 98
degrees or everybody look yeah or
everybody look you know but if if it's
actually you
you'll still be the knockoff that breaks
out if you're crazy left field
completely different
if that's authentically you
like
you're going to win
yo you got to tell gary about
how you're trying to bring like latin
trap with atlanta with rsvp because
people been saying i heard you say
you love that bunny whatever but you're
trying to do your own life
yeah well you have such an advantage you
actually you legitimately
like i was listening carefully you
basically lived
half your life yeah
and half and half in the two places that
are dominating [ __ ] popular culture
yeah like i tell people i'm like i
literally grew up like you literally
couldn't have made up a better situation
and he wants to be such bro
you love him he's [ __ ] first of all
he's just [ __ ] warm as [ __ ]
seriously
oh yeah he's a warm ass dude he gives me
back possibly he's a warm ass dude he's
like a teddy bear he's like good [ __ ]
people and he's talented as [ __ ] yes
that's the first one from panama 100
100
so it's like he's the better show though
you got to support the man it's cool
it's huge and he's really about it like
he's talented kid and he works hard
that's the thing i [ __ ] with sex with he
[ __ ] works
yeah work ethic is so underrated he's on
everyone now yeah he's out i mean he
just consists
tell us about the music tap talent
without work ethic it should was a
wasted opportunity
you understand yeah
it's [ __ ] a wasted opportunity yeah
i just think about that [ __ ] all the
time how many people
had loads of talent that either didn't
fight to find it
i'm always curious about that like who
was the greatest painter of all time
but she or he never decided to paint
gave up
yeah not even gave up
just no it didn't even didn't even go
uh novak djokovic
when i was chopping with him
had there not been a tennis court behind
his family's
um he never went out restaurant he would
have never gone there and instead he
would have been into skiing he's the
greatest he's gonna be when it's all
sent down the greatest male tennis
player of all time the serendipity of a
tennis court like
i think about that [ __ ] this is why i
push curiosity so heavy like try [ __ ]
just try some [ __ ] you were [ __ ] if you
said no i don't sing and just stayed
home and played video games or whatever
you don't know what would happen i know
what would have happened all the good
[ __ ] that's time last two years wouldn't
the [ __ ] happen
that's why i know that part wouldn't
have happened
like yeah yeah
nah it's crazy i spoke to that friend
yesterday for the first time in a couple
months you got to make a song about him
oh for sure
i'm a big fan of like music that like
paints a picture of a moment
that's the turning point in your life
yeah you gotta you actually have to
actually really think about that day and
like while it's still fresh because it's
only a couple years you need to like
remember that day to like you need to
actually like sit down and try to
remember that day yeah like what you had
for breakfast like
you know like what did i do and what did
i do was it friday after school or was
it on saturday or sunday it was a sunday
it was a sunday the next day we had to
go to school
you got to make a song of the first time
you went to church
that's a good one i'm creative
[Music]
you know i'm going to
i can't wait to drop my mixtapes
oh man we're good for you so young
whole life in front of you yeah
i'm excited for myself i'm excited for
you too yeah
there's nothing like the moment
when you find yourself
that happened to me like in fourth or
fifth grade
because i like really turned on school
yeah sounds like this ain't gonna be for
me yeah
and i was like what the [ __ ] am i and
then
baseball cards hit
in fifth grade
early sixth grade
and that was it my life changed forever
i'm like even though i was already doing
lemonade and shoveling snow and washing
cars that was like grunt work
baseball cards was like thinking like i
think this player's gonna be good i'm
gonna buy 10 of those i'm going to sell
that i became a trader instead of a
you know i always had like i still have
the grunt work grinder in me
but in sixth grade
i was i learned how to trade markets why
does everybody want don mattingly daryl
straw i started learning
really changed the course of my life and
like i knew i was home
you know
i'm 46 nft same [ __ ] i learned in sports
cards saying should i learn selling wine
you know collecting why people give a
[ __ ] why people want to wear jeans with
rips in them now but didn't seven years
ago but did fit 25 years ago the [ __ ]
cycles what what what like logos why
hairstyles why
why
you know yeah
that's interesting i think about that
[ __ ] a lot
sixth grade
and six i think about why people give a
[ __ ] about [ __ ] no i don't think about
sixth grade that often but when i hear
something like your story where like you
found yourself two years ago
you found what you were supposed to be
i got lucky i found it real early
mo some people don't find it ever that's
what me and drock were just talking
about yeah
there's literally things that still
find out about myself every day
i don't like this that's a hundred
percent
you know two years ago
yeah you got a little one yeah so
in the middle of that pandemic
my son was born
and
yeah it was it's like the craziest it's
like you'll think that shit's moving man
like a real movie my son was born the
only song i recorded throughout that
whole year
was the song that
opened up the first door
[Music]
and i'll never forget too because at
that time i was playing broke i had no
job no nothing and that someone was able
to make me a thousand dollars and i was
like oh i pulled it right out of my
district head and i was able to give my
son everything
yeah
i love that
yeah i'm able to do that you with this
mom yeah it's good yeah she's great
super supportive it's amazing when i
told her i was like yeah they invited me
to me
you know this guy she was like of course
i was like yeah i think they invited me
to meet him today she was like no way i
was like i'm serious i can't make this
up
look at the mess what was that moment
like for you when you got a dm like from
garyvee's management team like oh by the
way we heard your ep and we want to meet
you i would probably freak out for me i
was like
um i remember i went up to my brother
yeah he was like yo
do you know garyvee he was like garyvee
i was like yeah he was like
garyvee i was like yeah yeah he was like
he was like why yeah i was like yo his
team actually wants me to link up with
him he's like no [ __ ] way
i was like i'm like what do you mean she
was like that's so crazy
she was like it's crazy because
we never
they wanted any of this stuff
the internet
yeah the internet is so powerful
it's so powerful if this is 1974 there
is no disregard there is no uploading
there's no virality yeah none of this
[ __ ] there's no monday playlist
we saw we playlist the whole project i
was like damn you guys played this at
the whole project not two songs
we're gonna wake him up man oh yeah
we know something's about to happen we
gotta go crazy
yeah man nah i was just
i was just like well
thank you guys so much for that mike
we've been doing this for 13 years i was
down on typical everything back
matt taylor it was khalifa
man people need to hear this [ __ ]
especially with us recording it you got
to talk about what you're trying to do
with the wave music i think it's really
important man especially with you being
in atlanta yeah
okay so literally like
nobody has ever merged the american
culture and the latino culture together
it's where both coaches feel like
wow this is fine it's not a lot of
people that are 20 years old that live
10 years there 10 years here yeah that
have musical talent 19 if i'm being
correct yeah but
i round up yeah but i mean
yeah man you stepped in the [ __ ] talk
about time and jesus my goal is to
literally merge both cultures of course
because it's huge people feel like
you are that you don't even need to do
anything you just need to [ __ ] but
there's this friend that introduced me
to making music he's african and i just
lived and experienced this culture
for like the last five years oh so i i
ate their food i went to their parties i
dressed like them so it was like part of
me feels like i have this african it's
nice part of it so it was like what's
his name his name is joshua
yeah good people yeah
it's my guys his family is like family
they help me in my life so it's like
kind of shocking
how do you see your age yeah he's my age
i spoke to him yesterday
where is he here no he's in the military
hawaii stationed in hawaii
so he went to the military a year ago
yeah
yeah
and yeah pretty much i spoke with him
yesterday
he's great just making sure he's great
honestly if he needs anything if i can
help him with anything
just people really help me and
supported me but
none of this was going on 100 just
keeping it real just being real that's
what i just had dinner with really good
friend of mine
long before any of this
there's nothing like those people yeah
man
i feel like those people are like
they're the most special people
if somebody's lucky enough to have a
journey that
takes them to special places
there's always a feeling you have
towards the people that were there
before it started
there's just no other
there's just
no matter what amazing
love or friendship you can make along
the way
there's just something about it yeah
yeah like that's my god
my god guys
i remember one day i had to
take my son's mom to her appointment
we were in school
and i was obviously i didn't have a car
and he literally stole his parents car
just to give it to me so i can take it
like that's
my real
[Music]
you're nasty at soccer oh man you got it
like that yeah panama's also big-time
baseball yeah they i i would say outside
of soccer baseball's like right there
right there
and
it's growing a lot yeah i like it
because it's taking a nice turn instead
of it being more street more people like
wanting to be on the streets people are
like yo i want to play soccer which is
way better to see that then people like
yo
i'm gonna go
it's evolving a little bit yeah it's
it's involved
you've been in studios yeah i've been in
studio
i prefer to record at home
yeah but the studio is like the same i
loosen up it's like yeah this is what i
do so it's like own it
100 because you're wrong you take
control of it
create
and
yeah pretty much
and but yeah like the project that i
just dropped it was like a half and half
i recorded some of the studio some of
the airbnb's
um
one of them i recorded it in my boys
like living room
literally
it just depends
where you've been to the studio
yeah this one we're going through right
now
by the way
oh yeah dirk wants everything recording
and uh
the crazy part is i was able to learn
english in like two or three years
yeah you were still young you know but i
wanted to learn that
i was like yo i really want to learn
english so i got super into it he
focused focus just focusing
what about tv and music helped or you
were like more in the books
nah i helped a lot yeah right yeah like
i never had to like really pick up a
dictionary and be like i was so i was
born in this i was born in belarus in
the soviet union oh wow by russia yeah
so i never um
i never uh
i also had to learn it but i was so
young i was five
so super easy for me i like learn by
watching scooby-doo and the flintstones
like
batman
price is right also taught me that [ __ ]
i just watched talking about learning
something oh yeah you go ahead
need to have into it in a way that i
feel comfortable using it and that's
like interesting to me i was like
nah i gotta use it i gotta use it yeah
we'll show your process man yeah
just gotta think of ideas like yo this
is cool why not let's do it just put it
out people are interested in everything
[Music]
[Music]